what what did you say judge Abbott
chugga choo choo choo pitcher oh it's a
dese what's up man if you have to vomit
its straight or to the right to the
right over onto the people underneath if
you don't
[Music]
good morning good morning day three
how's Nina feeling you know I have a
huge sleep I mean I fell asleep sitting
up actually fell asleep sitting up and
then woke up at 3:00 a.m. to brush your
teeth and actually go to bed we're
heading off to Rotterdam today we got to
go to our passport check for immigration
and then get some food you hungry Nina
yeah kind of I'm so hungry had chips
this morning that was like that one eat
all right immigration is done we're
officially safe to go to Netherlands
Nina's at the library getting her daily
Sudoku she likes to Sudoku challenge did
you finish last one yeah what was your
time under five minutes pretty good I
married a smartypants
[Music]
we love her all right round two for me I
got some Froot Loops in some yogurt and
then I got some mini wheats for snacks
if we knew that there cuz Nina's gonna
get hungry all right we're getting off
the boat Nina's excited yeah she's cold
yes she's full lots of food
ready to walk it off Rotterdam here we
go
[Music]
[Music]
you know how dogs bark in Holland what
whoa whoa that's how dogs barking
Holland what you know you go across the
bridge first that's a very sketchy
looking for a ditch good Nina go oh she
made it okay
[Music]
it's a bouncing bridge
a lot of all right keep going first stop
is the Euro mast one of the tallest
buildings in Rotterdam get some good
shots with the city hopefully
[Music]
oh nice look at this here we are at the
top there's our boat way down there you
think this is pretty no it's prettier
you guys just let me say meanest video
okay look at this
there's Rotterdam you can go higher take
more selfies are this happening that's
okay
they're scared Nina don't look down
don't look down Nina yeah what's there
all right is that it is that the top top
let's keep going whatever you're into
oh we just sit hey oh it's gonna keep
this fire oh this is cool if you don't
make it back
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
I don't often film in a men's bathroom
but I got to show you this this is a
really cool tap you put your hands in
the middle for water and then on the
sides for the drying so if I put my hand
in the middle here you get water and
then over here
pretty cool eh how'd you like that hand
dryer what you didn't do the dryer
yes it's by the tap go to the tap it's
right next to the tap it's on the tap
you figured it out there she goes there
she goes
[Music]
pretty cool eh
I like the blow thing better alright
let's go alright next up we're gonna
grab some lunch at a famous cafe here
called the NRC the new rider than
Pompeii
make sure Nina doesn't get hangry and
hopefully enjoy some good Dutch food we
found our spot nice bench table right on
the edge of the street
pretty cool place Nina's looking very
cute today
[Music]
that's all I have to say we love me now
please believe nation loves you Nina
comment below if you love me
[Music]
I'm trying a blonde that's fear
can't pronounce that through average'
Nord and my Dutch friends gonna kill me
for that okay Nina try see what you
think
[Music]
nice alright our lunch has arrived the
Nina's camera is out we have soup of the
day whatever that is it looks good we
have croquette Dutch croquette oh that's
pretty big actually we could share that
and then I've got chicken in a pocket
chicken pita
try this if Nina let us know what do you
think
[Music]
good what's the flavor carrot butter
squash nice Nina loves your soup
all right done I'm feeling too full for
this pretty satisfying meal that was a
great beer enjoy nice relaxing
atmosphere yeah
next we're gonna head up to the vibrant
shopping active area and then maybe if
we have extra time catch a train to a
little tiny town and come back we'll see
Christ
[Music]
nina budd something what are you getting
eyelash glue I need some eyelash glue
get some extensions
[Music]
all right we made it to the train
station we're going to little city
called Delft which is considered a mini
Amsterdam that's 15 minutes away from
Rotterdam so we're gonna go explore I
don't have a map of Delft so we're just
gonna walk out explore hopefully not get
lost and have some fun
it is excited that's her excited face
[Music]
[Music]
Nina found something Nina founders star
but with the cup popcorn think I know
about how that one again
Nina's excited she gets this
[Music]
we decided to stop for some coffee
Starbucks we didn't go into we might hit
on the way back and you need to use
bathroom so we're going to can we see it
bagels and beans there's a sign here
look at the sign it says the best coffee
and bagels in town if you write a sign
about it must be true so with a shot
we're having a flat white 2 cappuccino
[Music]
Nina's taking the picture it's a
stronger cappuccinos what you said oh
the bells are ringing
it's behind you
nina decided to pick up some milk ax +
oreo let's try it what what did you say
choo chugga chugga choo choo choo
pitcher are you that excited to try this
new Oreo chocolate chip with chip attach
our pitcher all right there you go how
is it oh let's see the inside and what
do you think
good let's taste like Oreo
[Music]
like okay let me try oh my god so
criminal I took a big bomb it's so
creamy I still suck hmm milk ejector
took a chick abducted Chicka Chicka is
approved don't eat the whole thing you
know make sure you save some for your
amazing husband what the heck there's
nothing left in there
but it
Rose I'm so sad that's all that's left
of the Chicka Chicka Chicka mmm we have
to come back to where are we again go
come back the Delft just to try them
Oreo
[Music]
back to the train station get Nina her
Starbucks and then head back to
Rotterdam
[Music]
Nina got a mean I got a camel Alti I got
my buttered caramel popcorn cappuccino
cheers hey whose good stuff we need to
bring this at Toronto all right we are
back on the train heading back to
Rotterdam we're gonna go meet up with a
old teammate of mine at this was one of
the guys who built a good chunk of my
website initially
started off interning with me and
back to Holland when they heard I was
coming so if you gotta meet up so we're
heading back to Rotterdam and gonna go
find him
Nina the amenities her entities
available Dina's gonna meet him too and
so who believe nation simply fine
[Music]
all right this is the building where
we're gonna meet a dese he's not here
yet he's doing a tour that's a huge
market place inside he's doing a tour of
so when he comes out at 5:00 we're gonna
meet him
[Music]
I'll write that crazy big building is
where I'm gonna meet Addie so we're
gonna go in see if I can find them I'm
excited
[Music]
Nina's very excited about these cupcakes
mean it into the Suites well Nyna
chocolates chocolates inna
[Music]
okay we're at a traditional hearing shop
where you have to eat raw herring like
that so Nina look above you that kid
okay that's what you have to do Nina's
gonna get it he was gonna get that I'm
gonna go with the fried stuff okay we've
got whitefish and french fries we've got
some more whitefish and we've got the
raw fish okay so this is the moment okay
he's gonna he's gonna demonstrate this
is this is a demonstration of how to eat
it like one bite pay attention inna
there it is ready that was close
two boys okay Nina this is it okay if
you have to vomit it's straight or to
the right to the right
over onto the people underneath go go go
come on Nina how is it that how is it
decent yeah good good good
all right I like it no no okay this is
who we came to see a dese a DS tell us
about yourself
hi Michelle hi Steve well it's been a
while since we met I think was in 2011
yeah
we met finally in Holland in Rotterdam I
want to say welcome in Holland how do
you say welcome in Holland in Dutch
local welcome it's really tough
all right and we're eating some
traditional fish and chips scribbling
Kipling Kipling Kipling white fish Nina
finished her it looks good Nina good job
that's five boom we just finished eating
municipal I'm full but a deist insisted
that we tried the Dutch waffles so he's
gonna buy some and Nina's gonna eat all
of it there is fineness and Dutch
waffles waffle Dutch waffles the must
try all right this is it okay Nina go
[Music]
and sweet we just left of these he's
sticking around to talk to a client a
deist was one of the first guys to work
for me and he had to vouch for him to
come to Canada before he could get to
Canada on an internship he had to have a
company say that they're gonna voucher
him and take responsibility for him I
had no idea who he was and we just had a
Skype call and he had this super sketchy
Skype photograph of himself and you know
the call just worked out and I took a
risk and said okay I'll vote for this
guy to come to Canada and so if he what
oh well I'm trying to get your face in
you know if he came and did something
dangerous I would be on the hook for
vouching for this guy but I said you
know what the heck let's take a risk
let's say yes and it worked out and he
worked for me for a couple years in
Canada and then he left and came back
home to Holland to start his own
business and met with two of his guys
and he's doing well and so this great
he's getting married next year it's
awesome to see so bet on people ticker
is sometimes needs to happen okay we're
gonna head back to our boat get back on
board before it leaves and walk off the
food that was good but it was a lot of
food we've had a lot of food didn't help
that I had the ice cap just before 2:00
or the Frappuccino okay
[Music]
all right we're back on the boat I mean
it decided that we need to did you just
flex you workout and did like a bicep
flex there you go that's natural we
gotta go work out we're gonna see if we
can do some weights and some cardio burn
off some of this excess food see how we
do are you gonna do Nina new is gonna do
well all right okay hi I believe it
[Music]
waits done now we're into some cardio
I'm gonna answer some questions from you
guys hopefully see a chance good enough
let's go this is the view I get you know
my cardio
pretty cool so when I do cardio IO is
your cue a the audience on for about 45
minutes I'm gonna test out the internet
connection here see if I can get some
questions in get a workout in everybody
wins here we go all right workout is
done
good workout i cramped that at about 300
just over 300 calories but I got a good
sweat on Nina's still going though look
at Nina hustling in the back she's going
for 450 calories Rockstar look at me and
I go for 52 it's not right
it's even more are you stopping how far
you going up are you pushing you done
good job high five
you did well me man good job all right
it's about 8:15 at night we're gonna do
oh yeah the boats left boat is moving
slowly out
we are moving we're gonna go back to the
to the gym no we're not headed back to
the gym back to our room shower and then
go eat some food dinnertime
we got a towel animal what is that a
rabbit honey it's gonna say elephant but
yeah elephants don't fight down like
that rabbit Ted our shower look at that
shirt you could totally tell the
difference
Lina you can tell the difference I'm
sure Nina's ready to eat a humungous
dinner she said she's not that hungry
and then we'll see what she orders I'm
predicting lots of food you'll see it's
late - though it's 8:00 Pete's almost
nine o'clock like that it's a late
dinner for us but we had to work out you
know I wanted to work out before going
to eat right all right
see we got to get some good food in our
belly A's starting off with some drinks
Cheers
how is it
[Music]
all right dinner is done we are stuffed
so we have to go check out the buffet
see what's next what dance are we gonna
check out well there's always room for
dessert right I didn't even get to see
what new food there is I'm really full
tell me it's bulging it's 11 o'clock
almost for the long dinner the rights
that time you know those are fish
fingers Nina and spring rolls
Nina you're full remember well I don't
have a plate full of food I just got
with the ice cream machine very exciting
Nina's excited too you're gonna have
some no just me very are your phone
holy move a little bit on just a little
bit okay look that's probably way more
calories than the ice cream what did you
go get just to show it off let's see
[Music]
kind of drink is that all right that's
how you get to close the night with the
food all right sounds good to me so I
need a passed-out it's about midnight
right now and I went to the bathroom to
quickly record the final video message
of the day for you guys thank you so
much for watching
wish Nina a happy sleep in the comments
thank you for the love we'll see you
guys again next week I believe in you
believe believe in yourself now whenever
your one word is much love thank you
guys again for watching and I'll see you
soon